[Music]
so hello korea how are you doing
i'm very happy to meet you all hope
you're all having a fantastic day at js
korea first of all i want to thank all
the organizers of this conference
for all the hard work they've put in to
make this conference possible
despite the current global circumstances
unfortunately i can't be there in person
but i'm so happy that i can reach out to
you all in this medium
i'm here to talk about how we can make
the life of our developers much easier
who work on large mono ripples a
monorepo
or a mono repository is a
single repository that stores all of
your code
and assets for every project we will
look at javascript
monorepo throughout the stock uh in the
beginning
we will try to understand what are some
of the reasons why we
opted for you know like a monorail
structure for our code
then we look at some of the tooling and
techniques which can help you be more
productive
with mono reports i am jay santosh
and i work as an engineering manager at
microsoft
i am available on twitter and my handle
is adjacent
i'm from this beautiful city of
bangalore in south india
usually the traffic is much more than
what you can see in that illustration
at microsoft i work on a product called
microsoft search
where we build unified search
experiences for
uh you know like all your work related
content across
microsoft 365 app suite windows
and bing when you look at the search
product
you can see that there are multiple
components like the search box the
search results page
and a lot of other components which are
shared across the products
so that we can achieve uh you know a
uniform experience for the end user
across the products
experiences like search are what we
consider as
high value experiences which are
critical operations
a user does across applications and
across
platforms in the office suite
we also need to be more coherent to
ensure the search experiences
also look consistent with the rest of
the application
and across various apps and platforms we
have over 400 developers
who work on this vulnerable uh we also
integrate
the components we develop across the
microsoft projects like
office sharepoint teams etc and
you know we mainly call this as host
apps
let's take the example of a simpler high
value experience
like the people card the people card
started out as a simpler contact
information card over time this has
started growing in complexity so now you
can see that it has evolved in how it
looks like
and how much more feature-rich it has
become
let us understand it in a bit more
detail
you can see here that the people card
now consists of
various sections such as insights it
contains
recent activity conversations shared
topic
documents between you and the other
person what are the upcoming events
between you two and a lot more apart
from the contact
information of the user so it has
actually evolved and grown in
intelligence as well as
how much information it actually
contains
also each section is actually expanded
into even more detailed components
which are much much more complex in
nature uh here you can see that there
are
very like deeper conversations
components that you can see
the contact information is also much
more zoomed out
uh and soon then i
like you can have like documents between
the two people that you have
that you've shared or like that you have
access to
uh you can have access to all the events
that are upcoming
or the ones that you've recently had uh
the organization chart information for
you
uh in especially in large companies is
really useful
and you also have a lot more analytics
and insights that you can get
right so the people card now ended up
having more than 20 categories of
information
now let's look at what we do as a
developer when we're developing
something like a people card
if you visualize our utility uh we can
see
it is something like this we can break
it into two loops
the inner loop and the outer loop the
inner loop is
more of a you know a daily routine where
you write new code
test it locally create a pull request
and verify build and test reports
and merge it to the main branch the
outer loop
consists of actions after the code is
checked in
right so we deployed through different
range to production
listen and measure feedback propose what
are the next steps
to improve a feature or a certain
component and then write
code and go back to inner loop again all
right
so now let's uh if you just zoom out
a bit uh you can see that how we can map
this
in practice for the people card scenario
here the outer loop
is actually much more uh diverse right
so
it is more than any one given platform
so scaling out is really necessary uh
which works across
uh the various platforms we actually
developed to six platforms
as shown here like the web the ios
uwp mac mac os
uh win32 and so on in most cases the
usual norm
is that each platform is typically
siloed
for their ux and development based on
code base in people working across
teams is very hard it does scatter your
developer environment
cross-repo changes or roll back is very
hard it is very difficult to enforce
conventions across different reports
apart from all the software aspects the
largest problem is to tackle you know
the people aspect
so we are working with as i said more
than 400
developers across various teams and
all of these people may not buy into the
same goals
hence we looked at unifying the code
basis into a single source repository
and evaluate if it can improve the
developed creativity
to summarize the people card now has to
be shared across
multiple applications or host apps that
we call in the office 365 suite
as well as across six platforms in a
cohesive way
where uh you know the people cut still
remains people cut
but still has similar behavior and kind
of
looks homogeneous within each of these
whole steps and
also kind of brings in native usage and
interactability patterns
into the people to the same component so
we need to find a way to maximize
developer
agility here we started adding all of
this code to one
single repository or a mono repo and
this brought in more singularity across
packages
now let's look at what is a mono ripple
right
monoreport is a repository with multiple
packages or projects
it need not necessarily be a colossal 86
terabyte monolith
but somewhere where various projects and
packages can coexist
it also allows us to break our code down
to packages with single responsibility
and hence multiple packages which are
aggregated this way can help in
ensuring that even in other
repository or the host app repository
they can actually pick
a certain package and just use it uh for
example think of
the people being used in a calendar
widget
in outlook right so this way it actually
allows for use of small packages
across multiple host apps and other
repositories
having all of this in a single ripple
also helped us unify
processes across packages make
developers more agile
achieve more code consistency so even
for
developers new developers who joined the
team it was very easy for them to
discover code across the packages
and that way it was uh helpful to have
things in one place rather than
scattered in multiple repositories
for our work on people card it looks
something like this
one thing we focused on was to ensure we
break all the code down to
smaller packages which had single
responsibility
they say we were able to achieve maximum
reuse across platforms
uh for example here we broke the people
got down into
people data people are people core
which can then be shared centrally
across platform specific packages
like people web people ios and so on
so moving to a mono ripper meant that we
absolutely need to
nail and have reliable tooling across
various categories
like package management cross package
orchestration
linkedin testing tools build systems
infrastructure
and much more in this talk we'll mainly
look at
two of the hardest problems of package
management and
cross package orchestrators these are
some things that are very basic
uh in the essence of a monorepo and
something where we might end up spending
a lot more time
and lose our productivity right
let's understand how we can simplify
package management now
in a javascript monitor so javascript
packages
are the building blocks of any large one
javascript repo
the repository that we work in has over
to 200 internal packages we take a
dependency of
over 2500 external packages
for our components to work well with
each other and
with our partner repose we really need
to manage
our packages really well before we learn
more about it
let us first understand how a package
gets used
the package.json file is actually read
by the package manager such as
npm or yarn when you
require a certain module in your
javascript file
node.js will resolve this by looking at
the module on disk
right so the package manager actually
writes files to this
which then your nodejs process
kind of looks at the files that are on
the disk
so the key insight here is that node
will not resolve
uh anything by looking at the
package.json but rather
it will just look at the file with node
module resolution
which is present on the disk it won't
even verify that
if it is getting the right version that
is required or not
right so we need to just ensure that the
files on disk are actually proper
and that's where node can pick it up
from
so node module resolution is a key
concept in node.js
uh the basic idea behind this algorithm
is that it
recursively looks at for a certain
package that is required
let's take an example uh say if a module
in the
people code package depends on react uh
node will look for it
in the react in the node models folder
of people go
if it can't find it there it will look
in the node modules folder of the parent
of people core
and so on uh all the way to the root of
your hard drive
right so now let's map this concept in
case of a mono repo
i assume that we have two repositories
with package one and package
two uh with a mono repo you can see that
uh like both of these packages come to
the same folder
uh under a monorail right
we want to look at a few issues with
monorail which probably we can solve
with our current understanding of how
node resolves modules right
a concept package managers use is
sharing common dependencies
on disk because of the nature of mono
repo
most packages will share many
dependencies and there can also be
uh you know like some packages can be
dependent on other packages
within the mono repo itself so imagine
having two packages
like i said package one and package two
we have
three dependencies here uh on package
b and then we have where we have two
versions
so say package one depends on packages a
c and then a internally uh takes a
dependency on b
of one daughter version uh package two
also takes a dependency on
b one daughter version uh you can see
here that packet c
actually takes a dependency on
two daughter version of b not the one
daughter version so there are like three
copies
of uh b where we can dedupe a couple of
them
like b at one dot o ocean but still
retain
uh to ensure that c kind of takes a
dependency on the two dot o version of
package b
right so leveraging the node
module resolution algorithm you can see
that
now if we kind of install all these node
packages or dependencies at uh
the higher level at a higher level of
the
monorail folder you can see that if you
have these packages
under a node modules folder like you
have a b
c and c taking a dependency internally
or on b 2.0 under the node modules
folder
also you can see that there are symlinks
created to package one and two so that
say if package three later on
takes a dependency on package one you
can it can still be resolved
uh with the node module resolution
algorithm
this concept is called package hoisting
this is really great because this means
that we can now have some tools
which can help us achieve you know
package management a lot easier
right some of the tools uh that you can
use for
managing packages in your mono ripple
are rush js this is something that
microsoft open source long back uh we
also have
yarn workspaces uh you can also use pnpm
workspaces
you can use a tool called learner
so in our monorepo we use uh yarn
workspaces
let's just see how it works all right
uh to use yarn workspaces you add a
package.json
in the monorepo root folder you can set
private
to true uh add a configuration around
what packages need to be managed
by workspaces uh you can also use uh
like a regex pattern for having all
packages
in under a certain folder so that like
you can
continue adding new packages and you
don't have to change this configuration
uh additionally you can also have like a
no hoist
configuration say if you have some
packages where you don't want to hoist
them
to the monoreport route level
you can exclude them from hoisting
and then all you need to do is run yarn
from the root of the monorepo
so the package installation time uh for
i mean we we use 150 plus packages so
this
actually came down from 20 minutes that
we used to struggle before
to six minutes so this really improved a
lot of developer productivity time
right uh
the next aspect that we'll look at is
how to orchestrate
actions or commands across packages in a
mono repo
some of the popular tools to achieve
this are
rushjs again you have learner you can
also use
task runners like gulp uh you can also
if it
if your monorail is simple enough you
can even manage it with simple shell
scripts
right we need to use we need these tools
to perform
operations across packages uh usually
from the root
uh folder of the monorepo so we use
learner in our monorepo you can just
look at
how insane the logo of learner is
it's just quite mental right uh
so for using learner what you need to do
is add
a learner.json configuration file in the
root of your mono repo
all right so so that like you can
actually start
running scripts from the root folder
itself
uh you can add what packages to run
uh your commands in and then you can
specify
which npm client to use in our case we
use we are using yarn so we just add
yarn
uh you can also add uh the
configuration of uh use workspaces to
true if you're using yarn workspaces
so this is optional so if you are not
using yarn workspace or pnp workspaces
you can actually
set it to false so that way uh if you're
using
if you set it to true that one days that
you get is
a learner whenever it's trying to run
the
commands it kind of leverages the
workspaces dependency
resolution a lot easier right so what
learner does is it automatically figures
out the dependency tree
if there are some packages which require
some other which take a dependency on
other local packages so which means that
if you are running a build
command then it will require the build
command to be run
in other local packages first and then a
certain package
so this way it executes the commands
uh for the packages in a certain order
of the dependency tree right so
all you have to do is then learn our run
and then the script name
which can be run across all the packages
right let's see an example of how we can
use
learner uh so here i have a typescript
repo
of four packages a b c and d
simple packages nothing complicated it's
just a sample
uh that i've just written uh they all
have similar set of scripts
uh in their package for json uh here you
can see that there are some scripts like
prepare
watch uh run like run the build
use webpack and so on you can also see
that here package
a takes a dependency on b and c
internally right
now if we run learner and watch in a
parallel mode you can see
the order in which the commands get
executed right so
it actually first ensures that it
executes the watch command on c
and b uh packages first and then it runs
the watch command on
the packaging because a takes a
dependency on b and c and we need to
ensure that
b and c are compiled first and then you
can run
uh like watch on the files in the
package
so this really solves a lot of pain if
we need to execute some commands in a
certain order
and this actually saves a lot of time
for us right
one of the other things i really love
about learner is the scoping feature
in our monorepo we use different test
div apps
for each of the experiences like search
people
so i work for the project search so what
i need to do is i need to just
run commands or watch on the code uh
for all the packages that mainly pertain
to search components right i don't have
to
really execute or watch on uh components
that are
in people experiences if i don't have
any
dependency on them so uh
so this way it actually helps us to do
quick
dev validation uh during development
instead of integrating with different
host apps like sharepoint or office we
just use this test dev apps
to quickly validate our code during
development
the learner scope command allows you to
only consider a certain set of packages
instead of the whole monarch
right so if you define the scope using
learner run
and give the scope option and you can
give the
packages list of packages that you want
to scope
the command to so
this way uh it will allow you to scope
these commands to a certain package it
only executes command in
one subpart of the dependency tree and
this actually was a huge win for
developer productivity here you can see
we scope the command to package c it
only runs
for the packet c and not for any other
package so that way it actually saves
a lot of time for us right
some of the other very helpful things
that learner helps us
was to manage versions to publish
packages
uh to manage releases of these packages
really efficiently
so it comes with commands like publish
especially like some commands like diff
and changed
allow you to closely monitor the change
log between any two releases
very easily let's look at some of the
events that we got
out of learner so learn actually helped
us bring down
our build times by more than 5x so
even our watch times uh improved so much
uh and we continuously are trying to
improve
uh how we can like for a developer how
the productivity is always uh increased
right uh learn also has a very good
community adoption which means it's
quite reliable
it is adopted by popular javascript mono
reports like
people react router just and many more
to sum it all up finally uh pick the
right
tools for your modern repo if you are if
you are going for a javascript monorepo
you need not necessarily choose the
tools that we've discussed but based on
the complexity of the packages that you
have
you can improve the developer experience
and
ensure that you're picking the right set
of tools that are conducive and really
useful for your team
and something that your team feels
comfortable with
for linting unit or functional and perf
testing you can always combine it
with tools like learner or to easily run
commands across packages
additionally if you're using typescript
you should remember to ensure that you
manage typescript compilation
and manage the typings generated
properly so that
you can leverage intellisense and that
also helps in improving developer
productivity
to basically have a good robust code
that can come out of the developers
uh these are some references to all the
content that i've talked about
uh in this talk uh one of my friends
vincent has
uh written a detailed article on how we
evolved a large mono repository
right so you also have links to rush
learner and yarn workspaces
so you can go through it and learn more
about them
and yeah so finally thank you thanks a
lot uh
that's all in the talk uh thank you very
much i really hope this was
very helpful for you uh you can reach
out to me on twitter
if you have any questions or perhaps the
live q a that
might follow now uh so reach out to me
at jason on twitter
uh anytime right thank you thank you so
much hope you enjoyed the talk have a
wonderful conference